thank thanks very much I really do enjoy
coming here and I'm particularly proud
that my wife Ann is able to join me
today with my partner when Shay so I'd
like this session to be quite informal I
want it to be on topics that are of
interest to you and then there's a
couple of interest to me that I'd like
to share so you've probably not seen
this before I hope that you have but I
want to begin by getting about a half
dozen really important topics or
questions from you up on the board so if
you put your hand in the air and
identify yourself
tell me what's on your mind what would
you like to hear about from venture
capital to hot new technologies to
public policy to hot stock tips whatever
you want to cover
yes name Peter
cool education entrepreneurship from
Peter and I can remember the squirrel so
next question okay
our venture capital is going to succeed
in green nor does this may be the next
march of the lemmings question yeah your
name
internet-related okay online news
another one yes in 30 words are less
trite healthcare costs some more let's
go yes so the future for venture capital
right nothing short of an industry
analysis and prediction yes ma'am
developing nations or would you consider
India and China developing okay how
about two more yes
that's a really good question but you
know what
I don't ever try to speak for the
companies I'm invested in so that one's
off the board
two more yes absolutely great question
I'm going to cover that go ahead to hear
that and one more so what I thought is a
set piece we do is start with these
questions and topics I'll cover a number
of them through some slightly organized
remarks and in those remarks I want to
tell you a little bit about go ahead and
take those down for now I'd like to talk
a little bit about venture capital in
technology I'm gonna offer some
unsolicited career advice which is worth
exactly what you're paying for it and
and then I'd like to do a deep dive into
an area of interest to me and my
partner's which is the area of green
technologies and innovation therein and
then we can come back I hope for some
more questions or topics so we're gonna
start with kleiner perkins is that right
when we are okay very good so what we're
gonna we're then gonna deep dive into a
problem that that I'm actually quite
concerned about and I want to tell you
how I came to this concern it was last
summer sometime after how many people
have seen Al Gore's movie An
Inconvenient Truth so yeah after having
seen that movie which moved me a lot I
had a conversation they had an even
bigger impact on me we were having
dinner with some friends and we went
around the table to say okay what do you
think of this global warming is it real
or not is it man-made and there was
largely agreement there we then came to
my 15 year old daughter Mary and I asked
Mary so what do you think about this and
she said well I want you to know the
following I'm scared and I'm angry
your generation created this problem she
turned to me and then she said you
better fix it
and it's a it changed my life it really
changed the commitment and passion that
I have for this problem and and I submit
to you that not only did I not know what
to say it really drove home the impact
of what we're confronting we cannot
afford to underestimate this problem I
think we face really irreversible
catastrophic potential change and I
think we've got to act and we've got to
act very very decisively so I set out on
a mission with my partners at Kleiner
Perkins with wen and others to do what
we usually do when we see a big
opportunity or a big problem we go
Network like crazy we meet all the smart
people that we possibly can and we
mobilized and we hopped on airplanes we
went to we went to Brazil to learn about
ethanol we we went to Sacramento to
Washington DC we were in in China we
were in India we were in Davos and
everywhere I turned we learned more and
I grew more concern so I'd like to tell
you four stories about what we've
learned over the last year about that
and to set the context really to
understand where energy is coming from
and where it's going there's a wonderful
chart provided by the government that
shows the sources of energy you'll
notice on the left the sources and on
the right the uses and they're largely
dirty fossil fuels from oil gas and coal
with clean renewables up on the top to
the uses residential industrial and and
automotive and there's three big points
to take away from this the first is that
less than five percent of our energy in
the upper right hand left hand quadrant
comes from clean renewables the second
among the uses shows that you see more
than half of the energy that Graybar is
wasted it's in the form of waste heat
and the third is that if we want to
reduce greenhouse gases it boils down to
three things to cars to coal and
conservation that's the whole story
that's how we're gonna attack this
problem we're gonna need more efficient
cars that don't burn oil we're going to
need to find ways to make coal cleaner
because we are going to burn it and then
we've got to work very hard and very
fast on conservation
so I told you where networkers what we
did at Kleiner is we put together
something we call the green tech
innovation network and it's about 50
policy makers entrepreneurs academics
business leaders I mean from Al Gore to
Jay Keasling over at UC Berkeley who
just got a five hundred million dollar
grant from British Petroleum did you
work there on biosynthesis and and they
advised us we tapped their brains and
involved them in ways I'm just about to
tell you but the first place we went is
we went to companies because companies
are really powerful and companies matter
a lot in this campaign and so the story
I want to tell you with apologies to
Diana Ross child who lived there and
worked there is a bit of a story about
how Walmart went green and why and it
was just a couple years ago that Lee
Scott the CEO came to the view that
Green was going to be the next big thing
and he wanted Walmart to participate in
that so they made it a corporate
priority and committed they would lower
the energy consumption in their stores
by 20% 20% and do so in less than seven
years 30% for the new stores and then
they went to the stores and they said
you know the three largest uses of
energy are heating air conditioning
lighting and refrigeration so what did
they do
they started painting all the roofs of
their stores white putting in them smart
skylights that could harvest the
daylight coordinated with the interior
lighting and then they put their
refrigerated goods all of them behind
closed doors with LED lighting pause
there for just a moment think about it
why would you have an open refrigerator
and try and cool the whole store well
these other merchants aren't stupid
maybe because people would buy more
cheese and milk if it's right there and
you can touch it but Walmart being
data-driven went out and tested that
proposition they found no change people
will buy the stuff behind closed door
closed doors as readily as before the
net of this is these are all simple
solutions we don't have to engineer new
microbes to get this done their existing
technology and it matters enormous Lee
why well because Walmart is massive this
is the largest private employer in
America and that's the largest private
user of vehicles if it were a country
Walmart
be the sixth largest trading partner
with China most important I say is when
Walt Walmart makes a move like this as
you'd say go green to make money it
affects a lot of other companies who
admire them enormous Lee General
Electric Federal Express and so forth
but I think I told you at the start of
this conversation that my daughter Mary
was really scared and one of the themes
you'll hear from me is I'm quite scared
about this problem also I don't think in
fact we're gonna make it well why not
you say John if Walmart's doing all
these great things well when Walmart
achieves 20% energy reductions which is
fantastic it is a very big deal but
frankly it's not enough we're gonna need
all the other companies to act if on
average we're gonna get a 20% greenhouse
gas reduction let me turn from companies
to individuals and tell another story
about Walmart in fact one about Walmart
they have a hundred and twenty five
million customers fact number two there
were 65 million compact fluorescent
light bulbs sold last year and then the
stunning fact number three is that
Diana's colleagues at Walmart stepped up
to the plate and said we're gonna sell a
hundred million more compact fluorescent
light bulbs this year I think about 125
million customers that's practically
every household in the United States
third of the population and a hundred
million compact fluorescent light bulbs
that's what they've signed up for it's
not easy the fact about these bulbs is
consumers don't really like them they
cost a lot more in the beginning their
color isn't quite right it takes some
time for them to turn on you can't dim
them so my message to us about consumers
is despite a very large payoff like a
hundred million lamps means those
customers will save six hundred million
dollars a year and they'll eliminate
twenty million tons of co2 despite those
great gains which happen in just a year
it's really really hard to change
consumer behavior companies consumers
why is it so hard to change consumer
behavior I mean we use two tons of steel
aluminum and glass to haul our sorry
carcasses to the shopping center an SUV
it's
stupid we do that it's stupid that we
take water bottle it in Fiji and then
ship it here to the United States it is
stupid
that we dumped 70 million tons of co2
into our atmosphere every day like it's
an open sewer are people that stupid I
don't think so I think it's hard to
change consumer behavior because we
don't tell individuals how much the
behavior costs and how much co2 they're
generating do you know I mean we care
about this do you know how much co2 you
generated to come here today I don't
know I drove here and if I don't know
how can we expect other consumers to do
this those of us who care would act
better if we knew where if the market
told us but as long as we pretend that
this is free and the uses are nearly
invisible I don't know how we can expect
change and that's why honestly I'm
really afraid that we're not going to
get the consumer change that we need so
that my daughter Mary is not going to be
scared back to the lessons third lesson
that Kleiner learned is we want to check
out and understand this problem is that
policy really matters it really really
matters it's paramount and so I've got a
story to tell you that's a
behind-the-scenes story from this green
tech innovation network remember those
50 experts that we got together at the
end of our first summit a software
entrepreneur Bob Epstein who founded
Sybase
stood up and said you know the single
most important thing we can do about
this problem is go to Sacramento and
convince the legislators that a
mandatory cap on greenhouse gas
emissions is both good and good for
business
and everybody rallied around that we
said let's go and sure enough it was
just a couple months later that a dozen
entrepreneurs from Silicon Valley
largely business people and someone from
Google org went there and they met with
we met with eight undecided legislators
and the Chamber of Commerce was saying
at the time you know this is bad for
business it'll drive concrete production
out of California the extractive
industries Big Oil they don't like this
and that was the only voice they heard
until some other business exactly
came in there and said you know the
story's not quite that simple the
business community is divided and in
fact if you pass this legislation it'll
be good for the economy and sure enough
what happened is a month later the
Assembly voted 47:32 to pass the first
mandatory statewide greenhouse gas
limits in the United States of America
and they did so because they believed it
could create over 80,000 jobs in
California and add four billion dollars
to the income of the state and remove
almost 175 million tons of co2 per year
pretty impressive where California
starts the rest of the country can go
the United States doesn't go we're never
gonna get China and India on board but
as significant as that accomplishment
was you know California is only 7% of
the u.s. greenhouse gas emissions and
therefore only one and a half percent of
the world's co2 emissions and frankly a
20 percent reduction on one and a half
percent it's not going to be enough
let's go from a state to a country I
mentioned to you we went Brazil this is
a story about national policy right Tom
Friedman likes to say if you don't go
you don't know so sure enough some of us
hopped on an airplane and we flew to
Brazil to Sao Paulo because we wanted to
meet the godfather of the ethanol
revolution dr. Jose Jose Goldman birkin
and we asked him hey how'd you do this
thing in Brazil and he said John it's
really pretty simple the government
mandated that we'd have ethanol
distribution at all of our gas stations
and we mandated that the new vehicles in
Brazil would be flex fuel that's able to
run either on ethanol or gasoline and so
today Brazil has 29,000 flex fuel pumps
in the country compared to 700 in the
United States and a paltry two in
California there was a piece in The Wall
Street Journal this week I think talking
about the obstacles for ethanol the
other thing that they have is their new
car fleet has gone from 4% flex fuel to
85% and they've done that in four years
contrast that the United States we're
only five percent of our new vehicles or
flex fuel and most of the owners of
those don't even know it so what's
happening in Brazil is they've replaced
40% of their automotive gas consumption
with ethanol and they're almost energy
with respect to oil that means there's
almost 60 billion dollars they did not
ship over to the Middle East they used
to create jobs in their country and
they've eliminated 32 million tons per
year of co2 it's really substantial in
fact it's 10 percent savings across the
whole country in Brazil but it's not
enough
Brazil is only 1.3 percent of the
world's co2 emissions so even the Brazil
ethanol miracle is not enough and of
course we know too the problems with
ethanol you can't grow sugar cane all
around the world there's many issues
with us and all from corn you know the
bottom line on this is there's no silver
bullet but Brazil has grabbed a great
big bullet called biofuels and my
conclusion is my fear is I think even
the best of all the policies we could
put in place if we got them there could
very well not be enough the fourth and
final lesson we learned is about the
potential of really radical innovation I
want to tell you about a tragic problem
and a really breakthrough technology
around the globe a million and a half
people die every year of malaria that's
a completely preventable disease we can
go to the corner drugstore and buy
anti-malarial medication for a couple of
dollars and yet a million and a half
people are gonna die because $2 is too
expensive in Africa so with a 15 million
dollar Gates grant some scientists up at
UC Berkeley are bioengineering the key
ingredient in anti malarial drugs is
called artemisinin to make it 10 times
cheaper and here's the thing that blew
me away they're on track on budget to do
that if they succeed they're gonna save
a million lives a year
think about it a million lives out of
some technical work their breakthroughs
called synthetic biology Richard Newton
the Dean of the engineering school there
who died of prostate cancer a few months
ago a good friend grabbed me by the
collar and he said John synthetic
biology is the next big new important
platform it's bigger than the Internet I
thought wow I better learn more about
this but what they
he said what we do is we leverage
millions of years of existing evolution
in microbes and we redesign those bugs
to make them useful factories and so
they actually custom tailor the
metabolic pathways and you end up with
these chemical factories what does all
this have to do with green well there's
now a company founded by those folks
working on malaria called amorous and
their technology is being used for more
than cheaper drugs they think you can
make better biofuels which is a really
big deal because it says that what you
can do in the fuel is actually engineer
every molecule in the chain that makes
up a fuel and optimize it so as I was
telling you any other night if all goes
well we're gonna have designer bugs that
are swimming around in warm vats eating
and digesting sugar and excreting that
are biofuels or she said well John
that'll be better living through bugs
Alan Kay who was at Xerox PARC while he
was there he's famous for saying the the
best way to predict the future is to
invent it over at Kleiner we say the
second best way is to fund it and so and
so we're investing and we've decided to
do this just over the last year two
hundred million dollars out of a six
hundred million dollar fund in a broad
range of disruptive technologies green
technologies from cellulosic biofuels to
better batteries and disruptive solar
panels and coal gasification and many
many others and you probably noticed I'm
out there making a lot of noise about
these initiatives why is it honestly I
believe it's crucial that the rest of
the industry invest more in 2005 the
venture capital industry total invested
600 million in green technologies last
year had doubled to 1.2 billion dollars
but here's the point we need much much
more
we need R&D and investment that has
scaled with the size of this problem and
the size of the opportunity for
reference Exxon's revenues in 2005 were
a billion dollars a day and you know
they only spent two-tenths of a percent
of sales on R&D
two tenths of a percent second fat the
president's new budget for renewable
energy for an entire year R&D is less
than a billion dollars that's less than
Exxon takes in in revenue per day in the
third fact I bet you didn't know there's
enough hot rock under the surface in the
United States to provide all the energy
we would need for a thousand years it's
called geothermal you know what the
budget proposal was that was submitted
for geothermal research a measly 20
million dollars I'd suggest you it's
almost criminal that we're not investing
more it is criminal in green
technologies and it's why efforts like
Stanford has Berkeley has and others are
are so important and still in my opinion
underfunded so in a year's worth of
learning here's what we found out really
a lot of surprises I was surprised to
find a mass retailer who believed going
green was going to be really profitable
or who would have thought that a
database entrepreneur would move the
entire legislature legislature in
California transforming the state who
would have thought that a developing
nation in South America would become the
biofuel capital of the world and who
would have thought that engineers and
scientists trying to make a better drug
we'd set on a course to make better
biofuels most importantly who would have
thought that all of this is not enough
okay then what is enough what it's going
to take to stabilize the climate what's
it going to take to keep the ice and
Greenland from crashing into the ocean
well the science tells us that they're
guessing we've got to drastically reduce
co2 emissions to perhaps half of the
current levels even while the worldwide
economy grows and I'll say maybe I hope
we have the political will to chart that
kind of a trajectory here in the United
States but we've only got one atmosphere
so we've got to get a responsible
trajectory for the world and one of the
wildcards here is China the United
States today emits about 5.8 Giga tons
of co2 per year China is about 3.3 if we
stay on a course of business as usual
China will be emitting by 2050 23 Giga
tons a year that's as much as the rest
of the world total amidst today if we
proceed with business as usual we're
going to go out of business
not just a drill deeper on this when I
was in Davos part of our learning
earlier this year the China's mayor of
Dalian was asked about China co2
strategy and let me paraphrase his
answer he said the United States
generates seven times the co2 per
citizen that we do in China
why should China sacrifice our growth so
that the West can continue to be
profligate and stupid that's what he
said and nobody had a good answer for
him the only answer I can imagine is one
that's economic so that all the people
in all the nations do the right thing
we've got a use policy and harness
innovation so we can make the right
outcome the profitable outcome and
therefore the likely outcome and that
means is Walmart says that going green
has really gotta mean making green
making money saving money remember
energy is a six trillion dollar business
worldwide this thing is the mother of
all markets I mean you remember that
internet thing yeah it's still growing
and it's a big deal but going green I
think is gonna be bigger than the
Internet in fact it could be the largest
economic opportunity to 21st century and
moreover if we succeeded this going
green will be considered going green
will be I think the largest
transformation that we've had on the
planet as Bill joy reminds me since the
planet went anaerobic that is from you
know methane to oxygen I'm sorry aerobic
from methane to oxygen in our atmosphere
I said thanks Bill one more important
point I'm pretty sure that we're fast
running out of time nobody knows what
exactly the tipping point is but
greenhouse gases circulate in the
atmosphere for thousands of years
before fully absorbed there's still
greenhouse gases up there from Henry
Ford's original Model T and so this
problem is building and building it's
the integral of what's been done until
now we've got to plan to overachieve on
this because if we got to cut all
emissions in half that means we can't
count on everybody doing their part some
of us are gonna have to do more the cost
of delay here is really enormous I don't
see how we can afford to come up short
because the risk is really a runaway
it's like the people who start to save
for their retirement in the last five
years of their life they're not going to
make it so the hard question really is
if the trajectory of today's companies
individuals policies and innovations is
not enough what are we gonna do what are
you gonna do about your nephews or
nieces are you gonna do about the kids
you may have someday yeah and I don't
know I really don't I believe in the
power of entrepreneurs I think they do
more than anyone thinks possible with
less than anyone thinks possible and I
also as you can tell believe in the
power of networks the kind of networks
you're poised to build to continue and
sustain because you're in this very
special place and I think everybody here
cares a great deal about this change so
what's the call to action you know a lot
of people said well we need a you know a
Manhattan Project or a mission did like
Apollo to put them in on the moon and I
think that severely understates the
magnitude of this problem both of those
were really great projects but to get
the planet to get those institutions to
move we're gonna have to reindustrialize
the planet we're gonna have to change
the behavior of most of if not all of
the individuals so what's the individual
call to action for you those of you who
have this passion I think you should
think very seriously about having your
next gig be going green in whichever way
you choose to do it you get involved in
the policy process as an individual you
know right two congressmen advocate go
Lobby to make sure that one of the six
bills in the current Congress for
mandatory cap and trade on greenhouse
gases gets to the President's desk and
then push on him to sign it use your
personal set of networks and rolodex to
think outside the box
what would it mean if this school really
went green what would it mean not just
the buildings but all the lives of
everybody here what would it mean if you
move Stanford to go green
Stanford is the largest employer in
Silicon Valley what would it mean if
where you went next to take your talents
in your influence was an out-of-the-box
green thing what would it mean for
Amazon to go green or Apple or Google I
don't know but I know that well I'm
scared
generally a kind of glass overflowing
guy not just half full but overflowing
kind of guy and I'm pessimistic about
the way this is going to turn out I'm
hopeful you know we can't help but try
to work together as large and as
powerfully as we can as a group so that
our creativity and our influence gets
multiplied and if we do that I am as I
said hopeful that I can have a different
conversation with my daughter Mary 20
years from now that's green that's why
over half the professionals at Kleiner
are very engaged to work on green tech
in addition to the Internet no it's not
over
yeah medical technologies and in a
project we have in pandemics so I'd like
to turn now if I can to just a couple of
thoughts about kleiner perkins but most
importantly about what makes for great
ventures and then as I suggested this up
unsolicited career advice you know a
kleiner is viewed as and I don't think
we'll ever shake this as a as a good
quite good venture capital firm
collectively we've decided to try and
describe ourselves as an RC firm that is
as a relationship capital firm because
everybody's got the same money and I
think it's the relationships the
networks that you and we can bring to
new ventures that that make the most
difference so yeah we're a team of 22
partners and we've had as dean said a
pretty good value creation over the last
33 years that we've been there but the
most important thing about the
partnership I'm part of are in fact the
partners and they are just remarkable
they're technically strong
they've got operating experience in on
board there's three generations of these
partners in our firm at any given time
that's how Tom and Eugene built the
partnership and a number of us get a lot
of publicity like I do but I have to
tell you adventurous
as well as Google that's not a John
Doerr project that's a John Denniston
Juliette Flint bill joy initiative and
we all really gang tackle an opportunity
to try to provide services to
entrepreneurs and when we see a venture
with the right key success factor if I
can move from venture capitalists to
ventures we try to assist them like
crazy
I really think venture capitalists not
not be center stage our place is off to
the side of the stage kind of behind the
curtains and pulling them open for the
various acts in the performance the best
ventures have these key success factors
they absolutely have a plus passionate
founders they're committed to technical
and market excellence they're serving
large fast-growing markets they have a
reasonable approach to their financing
they have a sense of urgency but most of
all for our sensibilities
they are missionaries not mercenaries
what do I mean by that it's really
important and I was tuned into this by
my partner Randy Komisar he's written a
book about parts of this and you can
sense this when you're interviewing to
work in a company or a venture the
difference between being a mercenary and
a missionary is all the difference in
the world and while the world's not
quite to these two extremes you know on
one hand the mercenaries they have
enormous Drive they're opportunistic
like Andy Grove they believe only the
paranoid survive they're really
sprinting for the short run but that's
quite different I suggest to you than
the missionaries who have passion not
paranoia who are strategic not
opportunistic and they're focused on the
big idea and partnerships these it's the
difference between focusing on the the
competition or the customer it's a
difference between worshipping at the
altar of founders or having a
meritocracy where you get all the ideas
on the table and the best ones win it's
the difference between being exclusively
interested in the financial statements
were also in the mission statements it's
the difference between being a loner on
your own or being part of a team having
an attitude of entitlement versus
contribution or as Randy puts it living
a deferred life plan versus a whole life
that at any given moment is trying to
work
different screen just making money
anybody tells you they don't want to
make money is lying or making money and
making meaning offs also or my bottom
line is it's the difference between
success or success and significance you
can choose and to be sure early in my
career I was focused on my career in
telling money that balance will shift
over time but it's so much easier to be
passionate about trying to solve the
problem in consultative selling as
opposed to flogging some new breakfast
cereal with deep respect for the people
who are become brand experts working on
packaged goods you get the right values
and a team that's energized and
committed to their work and remarkable
things happen and we've seen that across
an array of remarkable ventures there's
a lot of logos up here I don't propose
to dwell on any of them except to see
that they're successful and then try and
be thematic what are the themes that
flow through these great companies that
can be and are being built
well we've organized our partnership in
a kind of semi strategic way around
initiatives and that's when several of
us like a team get together to focus on
something and historically they've been
the bits and bytes in the bugs and drugs
in the information tech and in the
life-science attack but recently we've
added Green Tech which I suggested is
all about Cole's car in conservation and
then an important effort I won't talk
about called pandemic preparedness which
in my alliteration is really a threat
that I think could very well be fast and
fail and for which we're woefully
unprepared but I want to move from tech
ventures if I can to his story right
from here from the business school about
social ventures in social entrepreneurs
because the remarkable thing happened
about six years ago Kim Smith a GSB
student raised her hand somehow sought
me out we found each other and said I
want to do a 380 to deal with the large
enormous intractable problem of the
deterioration of public education in
America public education that's the
largest most screwed up part of the
American economy
and of course you know what like a
carpenter with a hammer for a venture
capitalists every solution is a venture
capital fund and Kim proposed and put
together founded something called the
newschools venture fund which was the
idea that we could seek out education
entrepreneurs someone asked what they
are those are those hybrid combinations
of leaders who can scale organizations
maybe from business in educators and
know how to work their way around the
system that we could find those support
those help them write business plans so
that they can build scalable innovative
new schools because all the action and
education is at the school and with the
teachers they found that a recipe called
Charter Public Schools is really
sustainable and scalable anyone I
suggest can make a single school great
the real question is how can you make a
network of a couple dozen schools or a
hundred schools great because we got
eighty thousand schools in this country
and at least twenty some people say
thirty percent of them are crummy
they're killing the kids the kids that
only get to those schools have a
permanent cap on their lifetime in
California we even plan where we're
gonna put our state prisons around where
those crummy schools are that's not the
America I was raised in so what they've
done with about seventy million dollars
is back more than a couple dozen
education entrepreneurs and their
ventures who have founded and are
running today over a hundred new
innovative charter public schools
there's some in East Palo Alto there's
one in San Jose there so there's in
Oakland and that group is on track
without adding any more to it to add
another four hundred charter public
schools total five hundred five years
from now couple hundred kids in a school
that's a million kids every year but the
genius in this like with Walmart is not
so much these schools because I'm still
only talking about five hundred out of
eighty thousand but when you put four or
five of these in Oakland California
they put enormous pressure on the other
regular crumber from a public schools
we've got to get better or the students
leave there to get this competition idea
right within the public education system
this is really good work hard work takes
a long time commitment
I have to tell you I'm so proud to be
associated with a GSB alum they said
that she and others were going to devote
their life to this kind of work you know
in addition to advising entrepreneurs in
the commercial sector that there's power
in these social entrepreneurs who can do
more than anyone thinks possible with
less than anyone thinks possible two
more examples I'm just going to touch on
because I can tell we're running short
at a time
this guy Bono you may think of him as a
rock star wrong his passion is desperate
illness in Africa what he calls stupid
poverty these people who can't get
anti-malarial drugs and so the first
thing he did with an organization called
data is you ran all around the world
and I think he got 40 billion dollars
worth of unproductive third-world debt
forgiven it was just seeping away
dollars and obligations from economies
desperately poor economies that are now
being applied to education into
healthcare and then for his next gig
about a year ago he launched this red
campaign right that allow average
Americans everywhere who care about this
but don't know what to do to buy gap
sheet t-shirt or a red iPod or red
Motorola phone and have half the profits
of that go into the global fund on a
recurring basis with a five-year
commitment because they can lower their
marketing costs
it's co-branded right that red brand
begins to stand for something we'll see
over time how this story turns out but
he's the real thing as is certainly
Muhammad Yunus who got the Nobel Peace
Prize he was here at Stanford about a
year ago and his idea is that everybody
has the right to capital it's a basic
human right the idea that banks only
lend money to people who don't need it
particularly in a developing world is
stupid when if you've loaned 50 dollars
to a woman responsible for a family of
four with that she'll buy a loom or
start the business repay the money with
98 percent probability within a year and
start marching that family out of the
abject poverty that any of us could be
in here one odd out of three one chance
out of three two billion people less
than a buck a day or as a Bono says kind
of
where you live should not decide whether
you live or whether you die why are
these up here because venture
capitalists and Kleiner partners have
found a way to help them in their
mission again supporting entrepreneurs
you really have something that can scale
I want to close with some advice for you
it you know I certainly don't have to
take notes on it you don't have to
follow any of it but this is the real
reason I'm here today and it's to
suggest that you take your first
assignment based on your opportunity to
lawyer learn and grow they're not based
on compensation I was really lucky to
get hired in Intel and grew and learned
a lot build a strong foundation of
operating skills carry a bag that means
go sell launch a product you know manage
a dozen or more people learn about
really great management processes from
the best companies from the Amazons from
the GES from the googles and then
generally my advice is swing for the
fences when your time is right because
talented experienced leaders are going
to always be in very great demand now if
you're Jerry Yang or you've got a deal
with Larry and Sergey from I want to see
you at the end of this conversation I
don't want to say the only thing to do
is go great into a large company but I
think that's a smart thing to do so you
can make some mistakes and learn on
other people's money I do think you're
going to be judged on your ability to
listen and think critically and above
all communicate what I've seen is
people's ability to move groups
legitimately so is based on their
ability to convey ideas and sign them up
for the new mission so you want to
develop as Andy Grove and sister didn't
tell the art of confronting a person not
the person but the problem so you can
confront the problem without confronting
the person it's not that my partner when
Shay is a jerk it's that
it's it's something about his
performance and so that and neither of
those I hasten to add is true so don't
forget you need to learn all these basic
skills that Dean just alluded to I think
Lee pointed out the good fortune that
I've had in my career and there are
always always always in life extra
points for humor here's my
self-assessment of I think that's where
I want to go next
no I've got some more unsolicited advice
for you let's do this quickly
always Network go develop and sustain
personal lifelong networks and I was
interviewing for jobs
I kept the business cards of everybody I
met with I stayed in touch with them for
years and years and years I interviewed
as many places as I could
I spent time at Sheila Packard time at
tandem time at Intel I learned about the
cultures these places I interviewed at
Bain they wouldn't hire me I interviewed
at BCG they wouldn't hire me I
interviewed at Southwestern Bell
Telephone and got an offer and decided
not to go there but this is a tremendous
time in your life to go check out what
that world's like seeking mentors seek
these people who will spend time with
you occasionally because they believe in
you and want to help you grow in the way
that somebody helped them network with
somebody just Brazil every day you're
going to network with somebody to learn
about them and how you and they can
perhaps work together and once a week
for sure call your mom
I think it's good to seek positions that
have got a lot of external contact and
relations to take risk and to remember
always that integrity is a binary state
you have it or you don't and if you ever
spread your fingers apart and let the
sand a daily life flow through them I
don't think you can ever get it back
so this journey you're on it's long it's
a marathon but you certainly want to
live in this moment be present for
others I'm working on trying to make
better eye contact it really be there to
be present for my daughter we've
declared an email free zone in our house
which is from 6:00 p.m. until 9:00 p.m.
but you'll have time for you'll have
time I'm sure in your life for those
priorities we turn to in the end some
really clear questioning about what are
your priorities how are you gonna make
meaning how do you want to achieve
success and then someday how are you
gonna measure that success and so I
thought I'd give myself a self graded
report card here on the on the education
front I got a high pass at Rice for an
engineering and then I didn't get into
my first choice of business school
but I am really honored to be here
and I uh I built a career at Burger Chef
that was a very unsatisfactory and and
then worked at Intel that was a big win
and then joined kleiner and it's looking
good so far but I've taken I've taken my
life and said you know I'm gonna be
really nazi-like in prioritizing my time
so it's family first and then my
partner's second and then the ventures
to which I've committed third and then
always time for the new new ventures
forth and then sometime carved out
really measured 15% of my time
no more seldom less for a kind of
community service or giving back the
other thing I measure is how many nights
a month I get home for dinner by 6:00
6:30 but I'm in trouble and the teams in
trouble if I'm not home 20 nights a
month that's the goal while you've got
kids that are depending on you up the
other thing it moves me is books really
great books and so I have a couple to
recommend to you and and a way for you
to get get a copy of these slides now
some of my favorites are this one I
alluded to it's a Harvard Business
School book called the monk in the
riddle by Randy Komisar really about
meaning there's a great book called
banker to the poor by Muhammad Yunus and
then of course there's al gore's
Inconvenient Truth for a story that you
might think is fiction after one of my
famous failures called go the
entrepreneur Jerry Kaplan wrote a book
called startup it's still available and
he I think he should have called it
screw up is what I told him but it
conveys a lot of the intensity and
franticness that can be in a startup
venture when you get there so I'd
suggest you if you're interested in
joining a start-up or a venture backed
large company like a Google or an or an
Amazon or if you have have an idea for
something you want to pursue a new
business or an independent 380 I
encourage you to write to me my email
address is up there and in fact if you
were to send me a mail with
your three favorite books the one that
changed your life I'll send you a copy
of these slides and three more that that
I enjoy I get to learn about a lot of
great books that way so the bottom line
of this is to encourage you to have your
next gig have something to do with going
green that won't be that won't be the
honest voice for each of us but I hope
we can marshal a lot more work and
effort and energy on that problem that I
think is large and so I'd like to close
now by making sure we've covered these
questions throw a few more up on the
board and and then we'll be done we
talked about Education entrepreneurs and
what they're like Marya Lee no different
than tech entrepreneurs except they've
got some measure of experience and
really deep passion about improving
public education or education generally
the question here was about health care
costs and the role for technology which
I consider to be deep in significant
health care is the second largest most
screwed up part of our economy it's the
only system that I know of where the
payers the providers and the
beneficiaries that's the patients are
not connected in any kind of a linked
rational system and in fact I like to
say that Americans just want the best
healthcare that other people's money
will buy and in this this deeply deeply
lessens our competitiveness you see it
in the automobile industry so I'm
involved in a project and looking for
projects that will align the incentives
for the first time from a plan with the
payers and the patients and infuse in
that kind of web cloud-based technology
so that what it really is it's a
decision making business gets the right
information all of the historical and
the current data at the fingertips of
physicians who I think need to be more
empowered today let's see this is about
the Internet anybody remember what that
question was okay perhaps you'll ask it
again
online news you know I don't know a lot
about online news I think I've spoken
enough about venture capital and going
green great great opportunities in
biofuels great opportunities and
technology to clean up coal the hardest
and most important I think our
opportunities in conservation in
changing human behavior I'm very excited
about the work we can and should do
there and on the international front
some have said that well Clinard kind of
looks like the whole place is going
green and nobody's leaving Sand Hill
Road other venture capitalists or you
know doing franchises and opening
storefronts in China and in India I in
fact think it's really important we do
this is a flat world they'll be in
increasing amounts of innovation in
China and India and by the way for green
also in Europe and so I think you can
look for us to make some announced and
we've actually done them some really
major commitments three weekends ago I
went to China for a day and yeah no fly
there fly back more time in the air than
on the ground it is just a plane flight
away but it's a very very different
business environment and I think if you
have the aspiration which my partners
and I do to try to take this torch of
Kleiner Perkins Caufield & Byers
understand we're custodians of it we
want to pass it along for the benefit of
entrepreneurs and other partners over a
long period of time you say let's take a
really long strategic view what will it
mean to be the best supporter of
entrepreneurs in China a decade from now
and then I think you do a lot of
different things other than renting your
name out to a group of entrepreneurs
that you've found so that's view we take
I don't know if we're gonna succeed but
this is a good question and we're very
ambitious and committed to try to do
well there you may note that what does
it when a third of my partner's now are
Asian and almost that many are fluent in
Mandarin and compared to kleiner of ten
years ago a third of our partners are
female and I'll tell you it just it
makes working with entrepreneurs and
working as a team a much more diverse
much much better point of view we're
more effective when somebody's coming in
with an Internet proposal that's a
consumer Internet proposal about serving
women who have most of the purchasing
power on the Internet
I wouldn't want to compete with the
partners at Kleiner Perkins if I'm a
bunch of you know 30 to 50 year-old
white males someplace up on Sand Hill
Road because because we don't get it
okay we got time for some more questions
or topics yes it depends on different
audiences so I'm going to put it up here
and come back to it if that's all right
let's try to get a half-dozen questions
on the board okay that's a big big
whopper and we talked about that a
little I want to come back to it another
question our topic Al Gore 408 who would
vote for Al Gore in 2008
doesn't look like he'd win here yeah
well it depends its its plurality right
not majority
venture capital and tear I thought the
venture capitals were the terrorism
terrorism
now it's a really good question and the
work on pandemic is there yes your name
for profit conservation sits back in
green I should make a whole green column
over there dollars from conservation
get to more up here their remaining
minutes yes L peas and green return very
timely question okay that's it for
questions because I know we have a hard
stop here so the LP is on green returns
is actually quite easy by the most
successful I think three IPOs in China
last year were solar companies and the
markets are very large we've had no
problems convincing limited partners
they ought to invest in this form
special funds and so forth as for the
fuel pipe prices and getting in the
economics that there's a cost to dumping
these hydrocarbons in the like a into
the atmospheric sewer the answer here I
believe is mandatory programs of
cap-and-trade that builds carbon into
those there are other advocates who say
we ought to add a very direct carbon tax
which we could also in transition to
where we need to end which is where in
fact these green renewable fuels are
cheaper if you put in place a mandatory
cap-and-trade you've basically said
there's now a parallel accounting system
and part of the cost are the cost we
measures with today's accounting and the
other costs are going to be the carbon
costs
I was asked about what's that question
there can't even read mine
how do you communicate about green it
really depends on the audience if you're
with scientists it's a different story
than the one that I told you about my
daughter Mary though the personal
connection telling stories is key if
your
policymakers actually those those
stories work really well if you're with
entrepreneurs and I did this recently at
a great company called bloom technology
you've got to be incredibly
goal-oriented and task oriented and
specific about how their innovation can
really change the rules of the game but
mostly in the noise that we're making
not noise the message we're taking to
the market I'm trying to move investors
I'd like to see the venture capital
community double its dollars next year
I'd like to have legislators believe
that mandatory cap and trade is good for
American jobs how red china goes green
whether or not we get our green
automobiles from Europe China or Detroit
bears enormous ly on the quality of life
that you're gonna have and our kids are
gonna have I'll table if I made the
question of terrorism and venture
capital I think I don't want to try to
be good about that and I think on that
point we've probably covered most of our
many of your questions I I'd really like
to thank you for the time to be here I
like to come every couple years and I'll
be around for a few minutes if you want
to talk
you